[Music]
foreign good evening time for the Press
preview it's our first chance to take a
look at Monday's front pages and joining
me to cast their eyes over the papers
journalist and broadcaster Jenny Clement
and also the pr consultant Alex Dean
hello to both of you we'll chat in a
moment let's have a look at those front
pages then for you the mail reports a
record one in five first-time buyers are
signing up to mortgages of more than 35
years as interest rates soar
999 Heroes under attack reads the Metro
as it leads with a report that ambulance
workers have been assaulted nearly 10
000 times over the last five years
let's bring in the guardian leading with
a report but from union bosses who claim
Tory austerity left Britain hugely
unprepared for the pandemic
while the times features union bosses
criticizing labor over their naive
energy plan
The Daily Express looks ahead to the
prime minister's speech tomorrow where
he's expected to renew his promise to
end Small Boat Crossings
and the Ft says Saudi Arabia will cut
all production but oh production by 1
million barrels a day and a bid to boost
its prices
the eye reports that more than half of
18 to 24 year olds are worried about
losing their jobs to artificial
intelligence
and the star advises us to keep our
fridge full of cold ones as it predicts
hot weather this week and don't forget
you can scan the QR code that you see on
screen during a program at check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us discussing them and to do
that Jenny cleeman and Alex Dean now
very good to see you both this Sunday
evening
um Jenny why don't we start with the
front of the Daily Express
immigration in the news pretty much all
the time at the moment uh their headline
Rishi I will do what it takes to stop
the boats many people making the point
that he announced his Crackdown six
months ago and even Robert generic the
the minister saying that
progress has been slow
yes the Asylum system is uh riddled with
abuse and needs robust reform he says
which is amazing given that uh it we've
had a conservative government for the
past 13 years but uh this particular
front page is uh making the point that
Rishi sunak is going to say that he will
do whatever it takes to stop the boats
including uh spending up to six billion
pounds a year on it because that is how
much his measures have been estimated to
cost we spend two million pounds a year
putting Asylum Seekers up in hotels and
I think if Richie sunak was really
prepared to do whatever it takes to stop
the boats he would offer more
opportunities for for safe passage for
um Asylum Seekers the refugee Council
said today that the majority of people
who cross the channel in boats
do in fact have their Asylum claims
granted they're granted asylum in this
country we don't have enough roots for
Save passage for these people and you
know these very eye-catching uh gimmicky
ideas like Rwanda or putting people on
barges are very expensive they're
visible visible manifestations of doing
something uh but in fact if you really
want to stop the boats what you need to
do is work with our European Partners to
stop people's smugglers in Turkey in
Bulgaria on those edges of of Europe uh
bringing people in who will eventually
come to the UK and you need to make it
easy for people who have legitimate
claims to Asylum to do so without
risking their lives in the channel but
that's not what this is about ultimately
uh Rishi sunak has decided this is one
of his five pledges this is a vote
winner and he wants to do it in an
eye-catching way instead of spending the
money clearing the backlog
um he's going to do this very expensive
uh Rwanda plan and and also the barges
and uh you know I I think it's a great
shame
um Alex the government has eye-catching
and gimmicky ideas to solve this crisis
well no one can deny part of what Jenny
says which is the prime minister has
five pledges and it's playing that one
of them in political terms is outsizing
its importance for the government's
reputation for its future no one has
missed the fact we're going to have a
general election next year and this is
going to be one of the big issues
dominating at that election I also think
Jenny's uh right when she mentions at
the end of her remarks about the backlog
I would really hope that we spend um
some money six billion is a good amount
of money basically given how little we
put into our court system generally
um to uh clear what is a an aspect of
this that is not the fault of any
Refugee or Asylum Seeker or would be
Refugee or Asylum Seeker the most bogus
claim in the world might be on the table
here but the the one thing that isn't
the fault of the people in the system is
how long we take to process uh those
claims that is within our gift to try to
address and that is something we can do
I'm certainly if you're going to spend
this kind of money I know I'm a
recovering lawyer on somebody people say
yeah yeah more money for lawyers but and
if we beefed up the system of processing
people we would also beef up the the
speed with which they are sent back if
their claim is not true so you know
actually it's win-win for people I would
also see a significant rise in spending
not just on Border Force but on those in
this country responsible in our
immigration services or catching those
who are here unlawfully because in the
end the number of people coming isn't
the most significant thing it's the
number we send back that will get if
their claims are false that will get uh
people crossing the channel unlawfully
down in the end because if people
smuggle us here you're not going to be
able to stay in the United Kingdom for
their charges those people will go
somewhere else you're doing a lot of
nodding Jenny um so I'm going to let you
come back on this one just before we
move on
yeah I just wanted to say that all that
Alex is saying is is very wise but you
know spending money on on uh lawyers and
spending money on uh you know Finding
safe routes clearing the backlog dealing
with people smugglers in different
places is not a vote winner according to
this government's strategy as much as
you know these things that are gimmicks
you know putting people on Big barges or
sending them to Rwanda I really think
that this policy takes us all for mugs
really uh we can do better we're smart
people in this country and we can handle
the truth that just the government
doesn't want to spend its money in the
way that really is going to achieve its
day to days I'd say Okay
um Alex go on then very quickly one
sentence and now I'm going to ask you
about the next story
I see the point in his making but it is
a vote winner now that we've got so many
Asylum hotels and so many constituencies
full of people whose claims will be
taking months to process now government
taking a grip on that will be seen as
something significant I accept it wasn't
once but now I think it is yeah okay
let's move on to the uh ft because this
is an interesting story
um labor is going to get a five
um million pound Boost after landing a
new super donor The Man Behind Auto
Glass
Alex
yeah and we will all of course now have
auto glass repair Auto Glass replacing
our heads for the rest of the evening
um look one of the most significant
things that happens in our political
system is when people in business and
people with significant financial
results of their own commit they put
their money where their mouth is and
they commit to a political party but you
have no doubt this is really good news
for kirst armor parties need resource
like this and able to build up and run
uh general election campaigns especially
national election campaigns and for all
that people have said like this business
person has done that they disagreed with
the government's direction of travel
most especially on brexit few of them
have made this kind of commitment there
is of course the long-standing Lord
Sainsbury's been a donor to the labor
party for some time but donations on
this scale change what parties can do
and it changes what they can mount come
an election so this is one of the most
it's one of those kind of inside stories
that a lot of people won't pay attention
to but it's actually extremely
politically significant I think not only
does it show you a bit of direction of
travel in a business community thinking
about the prospects of labor at the next
election but also what labor can go on
to do at that election okay let's move
on uh because I want to talk about Harry
um and uh uh his appearance in court
next week Jenny because it is going to
be remarkable the first senior role
since 1890 I think it is to give
evidence in the witness box
um is he doing the right thing do you
think
well I mean he's made it his life's
Mission now to take on the Tabloid press
and most people who have the kind of
complaint that he has about press
intrusion illegal uh hacking of of his
phone stories obtained through illegal
means most people who have those kinds
of claims they settle and they settle
because they cannot afford to take the
newspapers to court and also because
they don't necessarily uh want the
scrutiny he has has the means to take
the tabloids to court in this particular
case it's the Daily Mirror but he also
has cases outstanding against the Daily
Mail and the Sun and uh he wants to have
his day in court to have his say to make
his criticisms but what is very
interesting is that he is not going to
have the control that he is used to
having that he's had uh in the
publication of his Memoirs in his
Netflix documentary or even in the
promotion of his Memoirs where he got to
pick who was questioning him he is going
to be cross-examined by defense
barrister in the witness box and uh you
know it remains to be seen how much he
is going to like that whether or not
it's going to be worth having his day in
Port uh his way of being able to make
the very strong criticisms he wants to
make against Senior Management at the
mirror historically for home phone
hacking claims against him and those
around him whether or not it would be
worth it uh for the potential
embarrassment will he be able to keep
his cool when he's being questioned and
scrutinized and remember this is a
person who has monetized his life over
the past year
um making claims about privacy it's
going to be quite awkward I think at
times people in court this week yeah you
make a very good point there um Alex no
cozy questions from the likes of Oprah
you know he's going to be cross-examined
by a KC
um in his book spare he recounts a
conversation with his dad when they're
talking about this and and Charles said
to Harry it's a suicide mission I mean
what what are your thoughts on it
it's just because you can go to court
doesn't mean you should and I think that
in the um clip story that we had on our
screens just now some viewers will have
noticed David Yellen former newspaper
editor saying but generally you find
royal family don't go to court because
it's against the media because you find
it's a case of mutually assured
destruction and so I think it will be
here
um not I mean I understand that on the
one hand I understand the kind of
bravery and I'm going to take my case
and I won't settle I'm not going to
settle for anything other than my day in
court but on the other hand you know
you've actually got to have the evidence
and
um you've also beyond the question of
whether there is evidence that his phone
was hacked and it was hacked by this
newspaper Outlet he's also got to try to
prove that the the management concerns
knew about it rather than being off on a
Frolic of the junior Zone and that's
rather harder I think uh to prove than
they might think so I really question
whether this was the right call from the
prince yeah Alex just quickly with your
legal background there's also an issue
isn't there that that these cases go
back a long way and there's a certain
expiry date isn't there
yeah but I wouldn't the in this sort of
uh case all of the cases are going back
to a period 10 20 uh years ago it was
the same with the cases that were um
reviewed
um in the course of
um the phone hacking inquiry that led to
the end of the news of the world and I I
the most important thing for me here
isn't the time after all if you've got a
claim in the end that shows he was
hacked some time ago people will be more
attracted to that and find it more um
sympathetic because he will have been a
child at the time or you know a teenager
that may be at one aspect that he uh
will look at and think to himself is
that something that the public find more
attractive than me as a grown up who's
has been caught in Oprah and so forth in
a way that Jenny uh says but the most
important thing for me is have they got
the evidence and just looking at this so
far outside perspective admittedly I'm
not sure his case is as strong as he's
suggesting yeah we shall find out when
we next week full color coverage of
course here on Sky News and Jenny uh
front page of the Metro depressing
headline 999 Heroes under attack bitten
head-butted spat at
yeah this is from the GMB conference 9
500 cases of this over the past five
years separately the the times has a a
story in its digital Edition tonight
reporting that pen the paramedics are
being urged to take police escorts to
more than 1 200 addresses for fear of
attack who would be a paramedic in the
UK at the moment facing all of this we
already know the hours that they work
the pressure that they're under how
resources are stretched the pay disputes
that they've gone through but the idea
that they're going to have to endure all
of this I would hope that we were better
than this but these are really Stark
figures that suggest that some of us are
certainly not yeah awful stuff okay
thank you both for the moment plenty
more from Monday's papers uh after the
break we'll be looking at more of the
front pages including the I generation
AI most fearful of losing their jobs to
robots the headline discussing that and
more from tomorrow's papers in a moment
[Music]
thank you
hello again part two of The Press
preview uh let's speak to Jenny and Alex
once again Alex front of the daily mail
um 25 years is sort of about normal
isn't it for for a mortgage when you
take one out but now 35-year mortgages
demand for them has doubled
yes well people are trying to find ways
to buy homes and one does know the the
headlines in the last month have been
showing a quite consistent drop in the
price of housing which must be good news
for those trying to get on the housing
ladder for the first time but here on
the other hand is them taking first-time
buyers uh taking on loans for a much
more significant period of their lives
than was the case in the past you can
see why this is attractive to Banks and
we've seen lots of criticism about
whether banks are passing on to their
customers the benefits they receive in
changing interest rates but here in the
mortgage environment vital for people to
be able to become property owners and
you might think there's a political
aspect to this too very difficult for
the conservative party to excite people
about uh property owning capitalism
Society they live in if they don't have
a property to own
um 35 years extremely uh long time my
notice of course that life expectancy
has gone up since uh mortgages started
really becoming mainstream in our
financial system but still it's a
dreadfully long time isn't it yeah I
mean that's right because you could end
up still paying off your mortgage well
into your 70s Jenny
yes I mean when you think about the age
of a first-time buyer is going up
significantly quite quite a few people
won't expect to be able to buy their
house until they're well into their 30s
you're looking at people pushing 70
before they own their house it's really
daunting and I think you know for a lot
of people we have been waiting for a
time when things are going to start
getting better you know we have had the
turmoil over deciding how we're going to
leave the European Union then we had
covid then we had inflation then we had
the disastrous mini budget and interest
rates and things are just not not
getting better meanwhile people are
locking themselves into to Deals like
this over such a long period of time
um something's got to give and who would
be a first-time buyer now I mean it's
it's not a great State of Affairs yeah
really tough okay you can read more uh
about that in the Daily Mail let's move
on to the I talking about AI in the eye
in fact this is a story that we we
covered on Sky News a couple of days ago
a generation AI most fearful of losing
their jobs to robots so this is a survey
that was done saying that 52 of young
adults um those age between 18 and 24
are worried AI will damage their
employment prospects and they're right
to be worried Alex I think
there there is a a reasonable point to
be had here isn't some some of these
concerns aren't illusory of course on
the one hand when we invented the
typewriter people thought stenographers
would all lose their jobs then we
invented the PC and people thought
typists would all lose their jobs
technology is always attacked and the
argument is always very often that what
you need then is to get a more
sophisticated uh Workforce doing more
interesting and more strategic things
and there is truth to that too but you
know it's not just removing drudgery
many of the things that people do when
they enter the workplace are Basics
which teach you the craft that gives you
the kind of
um Essentials but through which you then
use to go through the ranks in your
company and if those all of those Basics
are being undertaken effectively Now by
a computer then you've got to wonder
about where the person gets a role it's
not actually true that this just affects
young people and it's not actually true
that this is only going to affect you
know
um basic uh roles or entry point roles
in the way Workforce the role of
Surgeons is going to be affected as
computers when robots can undertake
surgery with a steadier hand and a
encyclopedic knowledge of every
Condition it's going to affect the most
significant legal work in the world
where computers and robots will know
every precedent and will understand up
to the date and up to the minute aspects
of every single case that's been heard
on this point in a way that no human
ever could but there is no doubt in my
mind that the first threat is to the
young people entering the workplace and
if you think about what that generation
has just had Jenny's just been talking
about the difficulties of getting onto
the property ladder let's also reflect
on the fact is the generation that went
through lockdown in education and very
often uh couldn't get in proper
education because their universities
were closed and now this too you've
gotta you know you've got to feel sorry
for them yeah you're right Jenny
yes I mean it's also that this
generation has the majority of their
careers to be working alongside AI as
well and in this piece in the eye it
goes on to say that most most people in
this cohort 18 to 24 thinks that AI is
positive is a positive thing so it all
depends on how they've been educated if
young if we're educating young people to
to regurgitate regurgitate things
they've been taught by roads then that's
going to be a problem but if we are you
know bringing up generations of creative
thinkers who can work alongside this
technology then it's not so much going
to be a problem I can completely
understand young people uh feeling
actions but also excited by the
possibilities that this new technology
can bring
okay and uh just to finish off uh Alex
The Daily Star we're oven ready Brits 27
degrees this week have you had the
barbecue out yet
it's gonna be hot we haven't taken the
cover off the barbecue yet but it does I
think uh look like this is the week
doesn't it show by the way the clever
Turner phrase our former prime minister
two prime ministers ago uh had because
everyone knew what a oven ready deal was
and I find a interesting echo of that in
the front today Jenny we've got barbecue
this evening can I just say and and it
was lovely 27 degrees is a nice
temperature for a heat wave I don't like
it when it gets to 40 like it did last
last year but yeah seven degrees I can
handle I spent an hour cleaning our
barbecue today uh full of mold and
grease is disgusting uh all ready to go
and we'd run out of gas went to the
petrol station I haven't got any left
either um thank you both very much we'll
speak again in half an hour let's see
the details for the weather next week